[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight all of Washington is
girding for next Monday six days from
now
that's when palo alto psychology
professor christine Blasi ford has been
invited to testify on Capitol Hill about
the assault that she says she suffered
at the hands of Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh sometime around 1982 now
both Republicans and Democrats say they
want Ford to testify on the hill though
no one has explained exactly what the
rest of us could possibly learn from
that Ford says she has already recounted
all that she can remember the details at
this point are thin including when and
where that assault allegedly took place
Brett Kavanaugh for his part has denied
that any of it ever happened
and so is his high school friend mark
judge whom Ford claims was also there
that night so that's where we are that's
the sum total of what we know and it's
still a matter of she said they said
without a lot more evidence it is hard
to see anybody proving anything
regardless of how many hearings are held
but that is not stop leading Democrats
from reaching a firm conclusion in this
case how do they know for certain what
happened 36 years ago
well because Brett Kavanaugh is a man
therefore he is guilty all men are
guilty
it's the y-chromosome watches Hawaii
senator and noted geneticist mazie
Hirono explains it not only do women
like dr. Ford who bravely comes forward
need to be heard but they need to be
believed
kisses perpetuating all of these kinds
of actions it's the men in this country
and I just want to say to the men in
this country just shut up and step up do
the right thing for a change did you
catch that it's not just Brett Kavanaugh
who's guilty it's quote the men of this
country every single one of them because
they're men Christine Ford meanwhile is
telling the truth because she's a woman
she's female
you must believe her that's a command
from the United States Senator it's not
optional it's mandatory so repeat after
me see her oh no men always lie women
never do one sex is evil the other is
holy
that's the catechism of the Church of
late-stage feminism does anyone actually
believe this nonsense of course not
because it's
dick ulis it's also divisive and crazy
virtue is not restricted to a single
gender or for that matter to a single
race and for a time it seemed like we
had moved past ideas like those they're
corrosive but now they're back in force
they're the inevitable terminus of
identity politics so because the left
has already decided conclusively what
happened in 1982 further evidence is
irrelevant as several Democrats
explained today there is nothing Brett
Kavanaugh could do to prove his
innocence senator Tim Kaine of Virginia
for example was asked how exactly
Kavanagh might clear his name the
senators reply quote that's kind of very
hypothetical very hypothetical it's not
very hypothetical to Brett Kavanaugh and
his wife and their daughters imagine you
were accused of a sex crime and then
informed by a lawmaker that there was
really no way you could beat the charge
no matter what evidence you presented
you could never be declared innocent
except in some quote very hypothetical
way how would you respond to that
you'd probably wonder what country you
were living in definitely not America
these are the Democratic Party's new
standards and it goes without saying
they are highly subjective they're not
applied to everyone it depends entirely
on how useful you are senator Ted
Kennedy drove his oldsmobile off a
bridge with a young woman inside he fled
the scene and left her but he never
summoned help he didn't want the DUI
arrest the young woman Kennedy abandoned
slowly asphyxiated over a period of
hours yet just ten years after doing
that Kennedy ran for president as a
Democrat he died a liberal hero the
Democratic Party needed Ted Kennedy
so they excused virtually everything he
did you're watching something similar
unfold with the deputy chair of the
Democratic National Committee Keith
Ellison last month Ellison was credibly
accused of physically abusing an
ex-girlfriend him Karen Monahan
apparently mazie Hirono never heard
about it because nobody in the
Democratic Party seems to believe
Monahan despite the fact that she is a
woman
his monahan put it quote I've been
smeared threatened isolated from my own
party all for the sake of the allegation
she made for daring to speak in public
well we asked the DNC today about
Ellison case and they did not have much
of a response quote we take allegations
of sexual abuse seriously and we're
working with the state party to review
the allegations right or confident it
will be a thorough investigation on the
other hand why would it be because let's
be honest none of us ought to be in the
investigations business in the first
place
political parties college administrators
cable news yappers all of us we're not
people you want determining anybody's
guilt or innocence we're not qualified
for that we've got a legal mechanism for
doing that it's not flawless but for
almost 250 years our justice system has
functioned pretty well in fact better
than any other country in the world it's
pretty straightforward if you believe a
crime has been committed against you you
report it that would include theft
embezzlement and yes sexual assault go
to the police
it's not always easy obviously but it's
still your obligation as a citizen not
least to protect the rest of us from
whomever you believe did it the police
investigate a judge or jury renders a
verdict that's due process it's the
cornerstone of our system it's one of
the main reasons people move to this
country from other places because it
works it's certainly fair than trial by
CNN or a summary judgment from
self-appointed gender judge mazie Hirono
so let's not give up on it it's one of
the best things that we have